many of our nation's elected officials
celebrated the life of harry reid in a
remarkable way mary jane belliesa shares
how many are remembering our state's
longest serving senator senator reid put
nevada on the map in terms of being a
political powerhouse when it comes to
national politics state leaders honoring
the legacy of former nevada senator
harry reid in a special way his memorial
service drawing a huge number of
dignitaries as they paid their respects
and reflected on reed's life governor
steve sisilak says the former senator
was a great nevadan citing reid as a
pioneer for the silver state he brought
projects in nevada that otherwise would
not have been funded would not have
happened here
he cared tremendously about whether it
was yucca mountain and nuclear waste or
it was for the affordable care act
brigadier general michael hanifan from
the nevada national guard remembers reed
as a huge proponent for our military
almost all the buildings that we have by
the nevada national guard in nevada that
have been upgraded since world war ii
have
been because of his efforts back in
washington d.c so he was a very very
important individual for us for making
sure that we kept a strong military and
representative suzy lee remembers reed
as the ultimate public servant for the
people his impact
it's not gone
he has you know there are thousands of
staffers in our state and in washington
who have evolved through his office and
they're they're still there and it's a
long lasting impact for those who
remember him for many years to come mary
jane vallieza live local now